hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the rake now if any of
you remember the rake or go back in time
three years to the earliest days of my
channel
laughter the Slender Man games were
first released there was also the
introduction of the rake into the gaming
sphere and admittedly games weren't very
good but I even did a dramatic reading
of it way way way way way back when so
why not play this game which has updated
things about the rake could be scary
nothing could be spooky right Oh
could be fun I got my good I have no
idea it's one of those games that are
like an indie horror game and you don't
really know how the quality is gonna be
but admittedly it's out on Steam it
didn't have the worst reviews in the
world so I'm gonna give it a go
cuz if it can give me a few jump scares
that'll make it be worthwhile do all the
time that the words don't come out of my
mouth right I just got done playing
vilasa box and I think I'm pretty sure I
lost my goddamn mind whilst playing that
objective pick up cameras well that's a
little different than picking up page I
remember that that's like the viral
image that went around for the rake and
whoo hello creepy smile Mount Charleston
search ends for missing six-year-old boy
oh my god the rake is actually really
creepy because the idea of it is
especially in that lake that top
photograph is in the middle of the night
you'll wake up and that thing will be
sitting at the end of your bed just
staring at you and then other stuff
happens it's not good
pretty much everything a bad about it
doesn't look the worst so far pick up
cameras have been completed good for me
oh I'm so good and I got rifle arrow how
many pain how many cameras do I need
whoa do you want to skip the stain ooh
seriously how many cameras do I need to
pick up med kit at least I'm stocking up
on supplies this is incredibly
responsible for me I even got a gun oh
boy I bet I'm gonna be so prepared for
this well this bright and sunshiny I was
expecting it to be a little more dude
what is that hey do you need a face full
of gun cuz I got a gun with your dwoing
whoa okay
all right he then so what am I supposed
to do I made a little mobile kind of you
want some what'd you say to me huh you
got a problem do we have a problem Pig
do we have a problem okay
so I'm under the assumption that I got
these cameras so I can put them out into
the forest so that I could watch the
Riggin right because that's exactly what
I want to do with my life because
apparently I've got nothing else going
on hey all right I'm gonna monitor the
[ __ ] out of this rake I'm gonna see him
and all his compromising positions
please
that legitimately scared me you son of a
[ __ ] what's with these pigs I know that
pigs have cameras on them so I'm
assuming that's like another
observational thing sure I just want to
have food that's supposed to be a swamp
boy I can't say this game looks good but
I'll wait until it gets tonight to
render my final judgment it already got
me a really bad scare for no reason okay
yes skip this day I did good I think
maybe
oh here we go all this where things get
spoopy all right
Oh Oh goddamn why is my mouse outside
the thing there we go okay it's back
inside okay we're locked in we're locked
and loaded we're ready to go what do I
do
apparently my guns oh there's my gun who
wants some huh
who wants some I got a lot of feed I
don't know what to do with it so anybody
out there oh and very hesitant to go out
into the woods all right well what are
you oh you're the pig okay
all right hang on they're a little busy
good job you ran right in now if only I
could pinpoint this rake creature boom
it's cyber night now
around the middle of the woods and we're
hunting a rig for some reason and I
really don't know what I'm supposed to
do I know what I'm gonna go out into
those woods and I'm gonna hunt me down a
rake never mind
I changed my mind what is that over door
can you stop that whatever woodland
creature that may or may not be you're
about to get a faceful gun I thought I
saw something down the distance over
there
what is that
where are you as I shouted into the
woods in the middle of night why are you
show yourself I see a low god damn it
you stupid pigs pigs are the spookiest
thing in this forest
oh god oh god you stupid Pig
that's not pig noises all great now the
music has started up that's a good son
alright so what is this supposed to be
alrighty then
can we tone it down with the wind
blowing in my ears
it's not very nice it seems like a whole
lot of nothing [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that what what the hell what was that I
mean obviously was the rake but I mean
why did that happen
[ __ ] tits
where are you
I hear some
Oh what was that I saw something you
can't tell me either
oh god damn it was that what was that
what was that bang boom Shaboom what is
that
if it's not coming for me now I don't
think it's gonna [ __ ] let it go what is
it
stop it there's so many noises so many
sounds what is that that's water
why'd you just scream
what the [ __ ] man keep it together
you're supposed to be the brave one Oh
what the hell what's going on now what
is happening why did I scream why why
okay this was not important
splish Splash I'm a taking a bath
I'm gonna grab on a rubber ducky
oh I hear a rumble okay all right so
there was some reason I screamed over
here well the reason I personally
screams is because this castle and the
game screamed what a big wuss
Wow big bubble blowing baby what a big
won't be wimpy won't piss world oh oh I
don't want to go in the cave of sinister
deep sounds but here I go
cuz I'm brave I'm brave or something
or something more like it
Oh badly what is that listen buddy [ __ ]
is happening
no no no what was the point of that I
don't even know what the point of the
game is it was like no instructions I
should have read the help at the
beginning of the game oh damn whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa Chism's whoa oh my
spleen
you punched it right out of my gonads
how could you okay well that didn't seem
extremely punishing okay then all right
why for what purpose I shot him I think
anyway all right then that really hurts
a couple dozen more of those and I'll be
dead you want to fight me huh
well I'll show you okay I guess he
doesn't want to play anymore
damn okay so anyway that's all I'm gonna
play this game
it got me scared a few times but overall
it doesn't seem like it's completely
thoroughly well made I mean I always
hate to be critical games because
whatever makes a game you know it takes
a lot of time and effort but all things
aside I'll leave the judgment up to you
so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other scare games
that I played in the past down the
description below and as always I will
see you
in the next video well that doesn't seem
very slender like
he's right there he's right on my junk